what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcus and
we have quite a bit of news regarding
the mcu today of course we have some
spider-man no way home news to talk
about but we also have some deadpool 3
news to talk about and some black
panther 2 news as well a lot of fans
were worried about deadpool 3 ryan
reynolds recently announced that he was
kind of taken a sabbatical from movie
making and with marvel pushing
everything back this made a lot of fans
scared that deadpool 3 was going to be
pushed back as well but don't worry i
have an update for you today and it
looks like we have some news that is
good news for the release of the
spider-man no way home trailer of course
i know we're all waiting for that and
some recent events are hinting that the
trailer isn't that far away so let's
dive into it but if you're new be sure
to subscribe so you don't miss out on
any of the latest mcu news and so you
can enter for a chance to win a
spider-man gameverse action figure all
you gotta do to enter subscribe to my
channel and cosmic culture and comment
on the latest videos okay so let's start
off with some spider-man no way home
good news yesterday or a couple of days
ago there was a supposed poster on a bus
in australia that was supposed to be the
official poster for spider-man no way
home if you cut my video yesterday i
went into detail about this but
basically what you need to know is what
i just said it was spotted on a bus in
australia and there's pretty much no
reason for them to use a fan-made poster
but people do crazy things especially
when it comes to spider-man so it very
well could be a fan poster on the side
of a bus promoting spider-man no way
home doesn't make much sense but it
could happen a lot of people are
treating this like it is the official
poster however we are not sure yet but
should be getting a confirmation on that
this weekend today the poster was
actually spotted again on a bus but this
time it looks a little bit different
instead of showing a full vertical
poster it's actually stretched out to be
horizontal so it could fit on the entire
bust horizontal wise and for the most
part it is the same it's the same exact
picture of spider-man and doc ox
tentacles coming after him with the
cityscape in the background and then of
course on the left it says spiderman no
way home this is now two photos that
we've seen on buses advertising
spiderman no way home again it would be
very weird if they were going to be
using fan posters to promote the film
because bus companies have zero reason
to promote spider-man no way home they
don't get any money for it people are
literally advertising on the side of the
bus so they are buying that advertising
space perhaps it could be a fan who is
trying to troll but reportedly we don't
have to wait much longer to find out
according to daniel rpk sony is planning
on dropping the official poster for
spider-man noway home sometime this
weekend that could be literally today or
tomorrow we don't have a specific time
we literally just know it's this weekend
and it's so crazy to think that fans are
getting just insanely excited for a
poster and i myself am excited and it's
just really funny because sony hasn't
really given us anything trust me i know
it's frustrating but it's kind of genius
by sony at the same time because all
anyone is doing right now is talking
about spiderman no way home not sure if
this was their plan from the beginning
or if they simply can't decide on what
to show in a trailer but whatever it is
it's working and i know fans are getting
frustrated but let me warn you about the
poster real quick i've been hearing a
lot of people talk and say well what if
it shows toby what if it shows andrew
what if it shows all three spider-man
together on the poster it's not going to
that is way too big of a reveal to show
on a poster for the very first time from
what i've heard from some insiders
marvel and sony can't really decide on
whether or not to show the other two
spider-man in the next trailer or not so
if this is true then they're definitely
not going to be showing the other two
spider-man in a poster this is going to
be probably one of the biggest reveals
of all time definitely one of the
biggest reveals of all time for a comic
book movie so that epic moment is going
to be saved for either on the screen
without telling anybody or in the
trailer but the poster should be
revealed soon and it looks like the
trailer might not be that far away
either insiders for a couple of weeks
now have been saying that the trailer is
most likely two to four weeks away they
also said that it was not going to come
before eternals and they also did claim
that the morbius trailer was going to
come out first all of which did come
true so that means that we could expect
the trailer to come within the next
couple of weeks however i have heard
that it's probably not going to be next
week at least not early next week from
what i've heard it could be anytime from
the 12th and on that's a time period
that a few insiders have said is when we
could expect to see that second trailer
however i just want to point out that
sony could release the trailer whenever
they want it could come early next week
if they decided on that typically sony
does release trailers on tuesday and
typically in the morning like they did
morbius the first trailer for spiderman
no way home was an exception because
they released it during an event but
right now that seems to be our best time
period from the 12th of this month
forward hopefully not too long some have
been saying the 15th but that is just a
rumor for now and now on to some
deadpool 3 news deadpool in the mcu what
a lot of us including myself have been
waiting for for an extremely long time
well since the first deadpool was
released at least now like i mentioned
ryan reynolds did come out and say
publicly on an instagram post that he
was taking a sabbatical from movie
making this freaked a lot of people out
because that probably meant that he was
no longer going to be working on
deadpool 3 and that it probably was
going to get delayed however when i
reported on this i said that there
really wasn't much to worry about
because the molyneux sisters were hired
to write deadpool 3 with ryan reynolds
and they were still working on it and we
have good news and this good news is
coming from ryan reynolds himself and
teases that a big update is probably
going to come soon when speaking with
variety and interviewing ryan reynolds
about his upcoming movie red notice with
dwayne the rock johnson and gal gadot
they asked him if a detailed update
about deadpool 3 is coming anytime soon
in which ryan reynolds replied soon and
he did confirm he is still working on
deadpool 3 in the interview he said
plugging away i can't really comment
right now hopefully soon though so this
is great news ryan reynolds took a
sabbatical for movie making but that did
not affect him with writing deadpool 3.
and deadpool 3 is his baby so i'm not
really surprised that even though he's
taken a break from filmmaking he's still
working on deadpool 3. and what's kind
of funny is that variety kind of
addressed the fact that this new movie
red notice essentially has deadpool
black adam and wonder woman in a movie
variety then asked who would win in that
fight between deadpool black adam and
wonder woman and ryan reynolds said oh
boy i think the audience the audience is
gonna win in that fight yeah and
whatever lawyer managed to figure out
how to bring all those three together i
think black adam would probably win that
fight but let me know who you think
would win in the comments down below and
now like i mentioned we do have some
black panther 2 news and this is kind of
the bad news which i spoke about in the
beginning bad news for a couple of
different reasons one is that the
production for black panther 2 has shut
down and the second reason is the reason
it shut down is because letitia wright
got hurt on set in late august leticia
wright was hospitalized after sustaining
an injury while filming a stunt scene
for black panther 2. she then flew back
home and the team continued to film
scenes that did not have her in it
however according to a report from the
hollywood reporter there aren't any
unfulfilled scenes left without shuri in
them so they pretty much cannot finish
filming the movie until latisha wright
is okay to come back to work so they
will be shutting down production until
latisha wright can fully recover and the
hollywood reporter states that it should
be early 2022. hopefully this doesn't
delay the movie too much we've already
had a bunch of delays happen about a few
weeks ago but hopefully latisha wright
can recover and things can get back on
track soon so let me know what you think
about all of this news in the comments
down below spider-man no way home poster
coming out this weekend deadpool 3 still
being on track and hopefully getting an
update soon and the unfortunate news
about black panther 2. don't forget to
subscribe and like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram twitter and tiktok and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof